elle a une loge en fait juste là on
passe au témoin du jour ah non
d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout le témoin
du jour c'est le débat du jour euh un
maire qui veut expulser expulser de leur
logement les familles des adolescents
qui dégradent la ville regardez on en
parle juste après vous dites si vous
êtes d'accord ou pas avec lui c'est
[Musique]
parti le 31 octobre dernier la soirée
d'Halloween a dégénéré dans une commune
alsacienne où trois jeunes sont
suspectés d'avoir incendié un
véhicule et alors que le ministre de
l'Intérieur souhaite faire preuve de
plus de fermeté contre les délinquant
avec une mesure controversée je pense
qu'il faut généraliser les expulsions
par exemple des logements sociaux des
familles à problèmes le maire alsacien
en colère depuis l'incident a déclaré
vouloir expulser de leurs logements
sociaux les familles des jeunes
suspectés dans l'incendie les habitants
en ont marre qu'une minorité vienne
troubler la quiétude d'un quartier alors
un MRE veut expulser de leur logement
les familles des adolescents qui
dégradent sa ville il s'explique dans
TPMP merci thbao philpps d'être avec
nous euh c'est très beau très beau nom à
chaque fois il est déjà venu nous voir
Thib merci PhIP c'est le mer d'
Kiren vous améliorez de plus en plus sur
la prononciation de la ville j'ai écouté
avant c'éit vraiment très bien très
bientôt à Strasbourg ah ben
je grand plisir viens là là très
prochainement pe pas dire quand mais
j'ai un très gros tournoi à Strasbourg
vous faites énormément parler de vous
aprèsavoir demandé donc l'expulsion de
leur logement social des familles
d'adolescents soupçonné d'avoir incendié
un véhicule de transport pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite le soir
d'Halloween c'est vraiment vraiment il
faut vraiment être des abrutis pour
faire ça-moi de vous dire ça excusez-moi
mais là voilà qu'est-ce qui
c'est fou alors ça et donc vous avez dit
derrière et bien on expulse de leur
logement les familles des adolescents
qui dégradent la ville oui alors j'ai
demandé au bailleur social qui a la
compétence pour demander et saisir le
juge civil pour procéder à une expulsion
hein puisque c'est pas le maire
directement et c'est un juge qui doit
intervenir néanmoins en fait moi ce qui
vraiment me me fatigue c'est que je
passe mes nuits d'Halloween et mes nuits
de nouvel an avec la police avec les
forces de l'ordre avec les pompiers
encore une fois on a été appelé sur un
incendie donc j'ai constaté l'incendie
on a une des description très précise
des auteurs et quelques minutes après on
a réussi à les interpeller avec les
forces de police et en fait au moment où
les interpelle où ils sont me noter on
se retrouve avec des adolescents un de
13 ans un de 14 ans un de 16 ans qui
finalement rigolent et ça les amuse de
se faire arrêter par la police parce que
finalement ils ont ils ont pas peur ils
ont pas peur de la police sauf que je me
retrouve après le lendemain à être
contacté par le propriétaire du véhicule
qui s'avère être garé sur une place
handicapée parce qu'il a il y a droit
qui a une fille aussi qui doit pouvoir
transporter ça fait 40 ans qu'il habite
dans la ville d'ilkirchgfen Staden et
donc moi je me retrouve un peu démuni
parce que je me dis mais en tant que M
je dois assurer la sécurité de mes
concitoyens et en fait on a 10 15
personnes sur un quartier de 2000
habitants qui viennent troubler
systématiquement pendant les nuits
d'Halloween pendant les nuits de nouvel
an laquiétude des habitants et moi je
veux vraiment qu'on assure la sécurité
et donc il faut des mesures exemplair il
faut appliquer la tolérance zéro c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est une mesure
vraiment exemplaire et très importante
euh Natalie vous êtes d'accord vous
pensez qu'il faut il faut expulser de
leur logement les familles de ces
adolescents oui clairement il faut
sanctionner pour que ça fasse
jurisprudence pour remarquer le coup que
ce
soit un véhicule de personne à mobilité
réduite ou pas bien sûr faut faire réner
justement la sécurité comme vous disiez
et je trouve que c'est une très bonne ce
serait une très bonne mesure alors euh
oui mais pour moi ce n'est pas la
famille de payer je suis désolé c'est
aux jeunes qui ont qui ont commis ces
actes qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
apporter d'expulser la famille à part
aggraver la misère soci dans laquelle
ils sont et ces jeunes ils n'ont pas 8
ans ou 9 ans il y en a qui sont
quasiment majeurs qui ont 16 ans
pourquoi on ne les sanctionne pas eux
directement et sévèrement plutôt que de
faire payer à leur famille qui n'est pas
forcément responsable de ça moi ce que
moi ce que je trouve ce que je trouve
vraiment dommage en fait c'est c'est
qu'à un moment en tant que maire je me
pose vraiment la question de savoir
pourquoi déjà j'ai des adolescents sur
le banc communal le soir la nuit quand
ils ont 13 14 16 ans moi j'estime qu'à
un moment les parents ils sont
responsables de leurs enfants ils
doivent assumer une autorité parentale
et donc quand on est en ou quand
onassume pas son autorité parentale on
est responsable de ce que fait son
enfant moi si j'avais fait une bêtise
mes parents auraient été responsables
ils auraient assumer leurs actes et
s'ils avaient été donc là s'ils sont
expulsés ils vont où bah s'ils sont
expulsés du coup ils iront où ils
veulent mais moi ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui c'est que dans ma commune je
puisse assurer la sécurité de mes
concityens des oui un peu pour voir on
on va faire un non un oui un non un oui
un non un oui et on fera ni oui ni non
oui oui Guillaume je t'aime beaucoup
mais malheureusement pour toi j'ai de la
mémoire et quand on a eu le débat
l'autre jour sur l'instituteur sur
lycéens qui avaient sifflé l'hommage au
professeurs qui avait été tué à ras tu
avait dit c'est pas aux enfants de c'est
pas aux enfants de payer c'est les
parents qu' faut sanctionner et là tu
dis
l'inverse tuétais pas là d'accord tu
l'aurais dit
autrement Gill l'a dit ah oui ah oui
sois honnête et Gill l'a dit et il dit
non voilà Gill voilà on connait g dan
moi je pense qu'un logement social ça se
ça se mérite c'est une aide que nous
payons tous euh donc souvent en plus
c'est les mêmes familles qui pourrissent
la vie d'un quartier ou d'une d'une
petite ville donc je trouve que c'est
une très bonne initiative voilà ça se
mérite parce que alors les Français vont
avoir à payer non seulement le log
social pour des des gens comme ça et
plus les dégradation souvent donc on
marche sur la tête moi je trouve que
c'est c'est un très très bon principe
Gilles mais c'est totalement délirant
excusez-moi monsieur le Maire je vous
comprends plus euh respect à Monsieur le
Maire absolu respect à Monsieur le Maire
ils ne sont même pas condamnés ils vont
être jugés en décembre vous ne savez
même pas si c'est eux et vous voulez
virer les familles alors vous allez me
dire vous allez me dire j'étais dans la
voiture j'ai vu votre témoignage ils ont
été mis en examen et alors et alors ils
sont même pas condamnés de quel droit du
principes sont condamnés mais SS sont
condamn parce que là tu fais le
débat oui mais je réponds monsieur mais
on tape sur les enfants ne tape pas sur
les parents c'est et les frères et sœurs
et les familles et les maires de famille
vous en faites quoi Monsieur vous avez
une ville où il y a des gens qui ont des
difficultés on est d'accord il y a des
quartiers difficile et vous la gérez
très bien ces gens-là vous allez les
mettre à la rue vous allez demander au
bailleurs social d'alerter le juge pour
les virer là je comprends pas je vous
trouve vous qui êtes souvent empreint
d'humanité là je trouve que vous n'avez
plus aucune humanité Monsieur le Maire g
j'entends ce que tu dis et évidemment
moi j'ai longuement réfléchi avant de
dire oui ou non parce que c'est vrai
qu'on que je qu'il y a quelque chose qui
me gêne qui est de mettre de la misère
sur la misère et donc je pensais au
départ mais en même mais en même temps
j'ai envie de te dire en même temps il y
a un moment où il faut aussi donner un
signal fort et j'imagine que ce signal
fort n'arrive qu'après une série de
mesures et que d'abord il y a la main
tendue les rendez-vous en mairie et
plusieurs séries de mesures et qu'à la
fin au bout du bout du bout quand il y a
plus de solution on dit bah écoutez
voilà
euh aux parents vos enfants vous
n'arrivez plus à les à les maîtriser la
justice va s'en occuper et et on va dire
aux enfants et bien vous n'avez pas
réussi à être dans dans le dans le cadre
de la loi et donc vos parents vont
devoir en payer les conséquences c'est
particulièrement c'est particulièrement
injuste Vale parce inje prendre deux
délinquants il y en a un qui est en HLM
l'autre qui est pas en HLM ils vont
avoir il y en a un qui va avoir double
peine parce que en plus de d'être d'être
justement à juste
titre il va être voilà inculpé ou enfin
voilà et en plus de ça toute sa famille
va
être
à celui et celui qui n'est pas en HLM
lui par contre ça va parce qu'il il a
déjà la chance de pas être en HLM et en
plus de ça et en plus de ça derrière
dernier argument quand même qui est
important c'est le fait que c'est dans
les pays totalitaires qu'on punit les
familles quand quand quelqu'un chose mal
en Corée du Nord quand tu fais quelque
chose de mal toute ta famille prend bah
moi je vis pas dans un pays totalitaire
Sophie non non on est responsable en
fait de ces enfants quand ils sont
mineurs en fait les parents sont
absolument responsables des actes des
enfants jusqu'à oui voilà bon jusqu'à 25
ans et bon après tu as des statutes tu
peux aussi être émancipé à 16 ans et
cetera mais enfin là c'est pas le cas
moi je comprends votre ralbol et à un
moment donné les logements sociaux il y
a tellement de familles qui attendent
qui sont sur les listes d'attentes pour
avoir des logements sociaux justement
qui sont dans la misère et qui
respectent leurs droits et leurs devoirs
je ne vois pas pourquoi on donnerait des
logements sociaux à des gens qui sont
pas capables de respecter aussi parce
qu'on parle d'un logement social on
ajoute la misère sur la misère misre sur
la
délin on parle de ça aussi on parle de
ça du fait que ce soit un logement
social et que ce soit déjà compliqué de
à la rue ça vous
intére mais là un truc de fou moi moi je
pense que en fait je suis d'accord Ave
les gens foutent le bordel moi j'ai je
suis comme vous j'ai envie de punir j'ai
envie de dire allez h dehors tu dégages
tu vas dans la ville à côté d'abord ça
vous garantit pas qu'il va revenir
[__] le bordel dans votre ville avec
plus de haine parce que vous l'avez viré
lui ses parents oui mais d'accord moi je
suis d'accord sur le fait de sanctionner
mais le problème c'est pas au maire de
régler ça normalement normalement si on
avait une justice qui qui qui est ferme
et qui et qui condamne quand il y a des
des de la délinquence ça tout va comme
ça de brûler une voiture sur des place
handicapé toute la petite délinquence
qu'on voit on voit hier un flic est
obligé tir en l'air pour sauver c'est
normalement c'est ça qu'il faut condam
dans
instant le maire lui il n'a pas à dire
c'est moi qui ve faire justicier à la
place de la police tuas brûlé une
voiture tu vas passer devant un tribunal
et tu dois avoir des SS il jus il les
gens g c'est qui qui moi je saisis le
bailleur social et le bailleur social
saisit le juge vous qui AZ demandé au
baurs de les sortir c'est un juge qui se
prononce et donc il a une justice vous
faites pas la demandeou je fais la
demande
parcejourd'hu faites justi parce que la
justiceis la justice ne va pas bien
aujourd'hui tu peux [__] le bordel et
tu es obligé que ce soit les mèes
maintenant qui décid de virer les gens
il y a le procès en décembre demand à la
justice d'intervenir c'est différent
merci bon on va pas rentrer dans oui non
moi je pense que l'éducation elle fait
beaucoup mais elle fait pas tout il y a
des parents qui sont dépassés et qui
sont pas responsables de de tout de
toute la galère typiquement il y a des
fratteries dans lesquelles il y a un
enfant qui est très très sain et
totalement normal et un autre qui a un
délinquant et je trouve que toute la
famille qui doit payer pour une connerie
de un et en plus de ça il y a a enfin
c'est qui tout double cette cette mesure
ça veut dire qu'il y en a peut-être un
sur les 10 qui va se dire bah je vais
pas faire ça parce que je vais protéger
ma famille à qui j'ai pas envie de la
mettre dans la merde et à côté de ça il
y a les neuf autres qui vont se dire je
suis en en délire avec mes copains je
vais faire la connerie et après ça ils
vont être encore plus énervés et s
mettre encore plus dans la merde des
gens qui le sont déjà je trouve ouais
mais à 14 ans tu dois éduquer ton enfant
il do pas brûler une place handicapée
ton enfant à 14 ans c'est c'est que ta
merder sur l'édation mer d'accord mais
n'empêche que il faut punir les
personnes qui ont fait les problèmes
mais pas famille a pas de bon solution
en fait sondage
oui voil regarde le sondage oui à
90% incroyable voilà un
plébisc parce que vous voyez ci moi moi
je cro je crois vraiment en la justice
de mon pays malheureusement aujourd'hui
ce que je constate c'est que quand on
interpelle des gens en flagrant d'li on
les amène devant l'officier de police
judiciaire et en fait bien souvent ces
personnesl sont dehors avant même qu'on
a terminé de rédiger la procédure et
donc ça ça il y a un vrai problème et je
pense que c'est aussi en sais en
saisissant la justice qu'on arrivera à
la faire progresser et donc c'est un
moment le maire dans les lois le maire
il est en responsabilité d'assurer la
sécurité sur son ban communal
% 98% c'est pas négligable 9,8% voilà
exuseo vousez beaucoup grave c'est grave
atts
jeir moi ça me dérange pas
9,8% la vérité s'inscrit parfois dans le
cours de l'Histoire j'aurais raison
demain pas aujourd'hui voilà c'est tout
quoi fa en fait c'est pas ça vous aviez
raison il y a 20
ans avz
Rais plus JIS Rais on est triste de dire
ça
alors les gens qui sont des humanistes
plus jamais raisoniste
laiss faire
c'est vous nêes pas un humaniste
excuse-moius tu es pas un humaniste
humaniste dans la vie c'est vra que Mo
j'aime parce que tu me donnes souvent du
chocolat tout
ça un rveur
exour auourd'hui on pe r qu'est-ce que
tu penses de ton voisin non mais le
laxisme c'est fini on ne peut plus on
peut plus c'est un privilège d'avoir log
à mer
monsur beauoup